let's begin our Ingram angle special
report on the Russian cloud with a look
at Spygate that's what president Trump
calls the growing reports at the FBI
under Obama placed at least one
informant or spy in his presidential
campaign those reports also fuels
suspicion on the right that the Russia
investigation has been nothing more than
a political coup by Obama allies in the
deep State against the duly elected
president of the United States in the
era of an exploding surveillance state
have we actually witnessed an
administration infiltrate the
presidential campaign of the opposing
party an editorial in Wednesday's
investor's business daily points out how
timing is everything the IBD noted that
the timeline of the FBI's Russian
investigation keeps shifting and the
earlier the probe began quote the less
likely it is that it had anything to do
with Russian involvement in the 2016
elections but everything to do with
stopping the surprising surge of Trump
during the GOP primaries and beyond
let's examine that prospect with some
top-notch experts former FBI Special
Agent Jeff Beatty is in Orlando in
Washington bill Benny who served more
than 30 years as a top Intel official
with the NSA before turning
whistleblower and here in New York Steve
Rogers a former member of FBI Joint
Terrorism Task Force Steve we'll start
with you I have a theory here and one's
bad and one's a little worse first the
Obama administration thought there was
Russian infiltration so they used the
Trump officials as bait in order to lure
the Russians in but nothing materialized
then they looked around they thought you
know I have some Trump people on the
hook here let's turn the screws or it
was deceitful from the very beginning
they wanted eyes and ears on the Trump
campaign so without any probable cause
they cooked up this echo chamber of
spies and lies and misinformation to get
the surveillance what do you think Jesse
if they were going for the Russians they
would have gone to the Trump campaign
they would have their in their hands the
greatest assets of human intelligence
right in the Trump campaign they were
why are those individuals up and said
look the Russians are coming after you
we need you we need to wire you up let's
trap the Russians it was the sequel from
the beginning they were never going
after the Russian Jesse they were going
after Donald Trump yeah you know Bill
where are the Russians here in this
investigation because we we see a lot of
spies and FBI people we haven't seen a
lot of Russian spies have they ever
materialized not that I can see I mean
even the evidence they put forth to say
was a Russian hack from gusoff or -
turns out to be a very clear fabrication
in fact a very poor one and it's
provable through forensics that it's not
that it's not a valid download remotely
so I mean all of it was fabricated so
Jeff like like Bill just mentioned this
all started with the so-called hack of
the Democrats computers now the
counter-intel investigation opened up a
couple weeks after the emails release in
the summer with debbie Wasserman Schultz
remember they rigged the primary all
that stuff why didn't the FBI then go
look at this server at the DNC and do a
forensic audit I mean wouldn't that be
the first place you'd look if you were
looking for Russian infiltration well
you know that goes back to 2015 and I'm
a I'm a believer in your course of
action - that you outlined at the top of
the show Jesse but let me just give you
what I see as the bluff the bottom line
up front you know they the FBI gave a
defensive briefing to the Democratic
National Committee when they had
information that there was a foreign
entity trying to sway influence or move
into or penetrate the democratic
apparatus they did not do that for the
Republican apparatus as Steve alluded to
you know what they did from the very
beginning was treat the Republican
apparatus differently Democrat defensive
briefing let's work together Republican
I really think it was nothing but a fig
leaf to use other government agencies to
introduce a Russian raison d'etre to
explain why they could then go ahead
launch an investigation for two purposes
Jesse I think first
to get to get political intelligence as
to what was going on on the inside of my
campaign so that they could use it but
secondly to be able to destroy their
enemy these guys not to use a Chris
Matthews reference these guys we're
playing hardball
and you know please note these
references on the show let me just get
it you destroyed your enemy or they'll
destroy you right so they have
suspicions about either page or man
afford or Papadopoulos in the spring and
instead of maybe interviewing
Papadopoulos or Paige or whoever man
afford they don't do any of that they
don't even alert Donald Trump that they
you know hey we're supposed to protect
you maybe you know there could be some
issues instead they just wiretap
everybody and send spy rings throughout
the whole campaign it doesn't seem like
an anti Russia operation it seems like
an anti they didn't even go into the DNC
to see if there was a Russian in there
opening a backdoor to the servers
the stage was set the day James Comey
testified before Congress and gave
Hillary Clinton of pass never really
pursued the 33,000 missing emails number
one what happened to Bill Clinton and
the famous tart tarmac meeting at the
airport with Loretta rich they gave her
a pass and now as I said earlier why
didn't they go to the Trump campaign and
say look we think the Russians are
coming what we need you to do is to wire
your people up we want to trap the
Russians they tried to trap President
Donald Trump and they because they had
them all wired we're all copied I mean
everything once you get one person in
the campaign you have the whole campaign
that's a to hot principle that's right
and they have these guys were coming in
and out of Trump Tower the other couple
guys were overseas they threw everything
at this campaign they threw spies
informants and secret subpoenas
electronic surveillance fake dossiers
unmasking every technicality that you've
used in an investigation they threw
everything at these guys and you know
what Donald Trump still won the election
yeah
what does that say no evidence no
evidence of collusion no right and keep
in mind though Jesse that they're using
the NSA databases to do all this spying
and those go back to 2001 so they can
retroactively lis analyze all the data
on everyone in the campaign right now
clapper as we all remember one of the
top intelligence chiefs under President
Barack Obama has been doing the rounds
on television and he disputes the whole
spying thing kind of here's his spin
I think he's deliberately spinning a
narrative that whereby he's a victim of
the deep state spying on him or spying
on the campaign which is it's not the
case it's my what I would call my
informed opinion that given the massive
effort the Russians made and the number
of citizens that they touch to me it
just exceeds logic and credulity that
they didn't affect the election and it's
my belief they actually turned it so I
ask you was the FBI spying on Trump's
campaign no they were not they were
spying on a term I don't particularly
like but on what the Russians were doing
why doesn't he like that he should be
happy they should be okay first of all
the James clapper is on the view I don't
think the top Intel guy for many teams
should be on the view second of all he
just admitted they spied but wait they
were just trying to help
president Trump president Trump should
thank them for spying on the campaign
right Jesse one thing you said opening
up and the question is did the Obama
administration know about this did the
Justice Department under Obama know
about this I don't believe for one
minute they didn't know I believe Obama
knew about what was going on I believe
his Justice Department knew what was
going on and it's all falling apart they
know that's a great point bill we have
evidence that the White House was in the
loop on this we have some page Strock
texts at one point they say quote the
White House is running this talking
about this counterintelligence operation
there are these briefings with the top
people and the Obama team White House
chief of staff was in on the loop on
this how could Obama not know that the
was happening I mean after all when you
have the it just take the steel dossier
for example that that was some fellow
from mi6 which is the equivalent of CIA
and then CIA was involved FBI was
involved in the Department of Justice
the only place those those organizations
come to a point where it can be ordered
and coordinated is that the president
yeah we do have records now that this
spy or whatever you want to call him
over there in England he was getting
paid pretty handsomely yeah by the Obama
administration right around the same
time he was running these dirty tricks
this guy was connected to mi6 CIA he'd
done some dirty tricks and elections in
the past he'd been outspoken yeah about
his support for Hillary Clinton and even
tried to get a job within the Trump
administration afterwards so Jeff I mean
it's it's all coming apart it is you
know and to see clapper and Brennan out
there with the titles of you know former
director etc you know these guys are no
longer intelligence officials and it's
time for the president to start striking
back at them and and by that I mean a
lot of these senior people get to keep
their security clearances so that they
can consult with in people with
government there's no need for there to
have security clearances anymore start
taking away Brennan security clearance
or access to anything clapper security
clearance or access to anything because
they have become partisans they are not
out there doing what they're supposed to
have done as professionals which is to
do your job and be blind be agnostic
when it comes to party politics move to
make and I think President Trump would
probably make that move or at least
flirt with doing that you brought up an
interesting point about people though
still in the FBI are still in the DOJ
that do have these clearances we're
hearing word here at Fox News that there
may be some people coming forward maybe
some whistleblowers that might like to
talk about how James Comey ran these
operations how we dealt with the
Clintons how we dealt with the Trump
campaign but just go around if you guys
were still in the government would you
guys come forward and testifying lawyer
well the good news is the OIG reports
about to come out and the OIG has the
ability to protect the whistleblowers
within the Department of Justice and
within the FBI so hopeful optimistic
that some of those folks will see do the
right thing and get protected by the OIG
and we might see some of their content
coming out in his report yes they need
to break down the blue wall of silence
when the ship is sinking no one is gonna
throw you a life raft and bill what do
you think well I mean according to the
Constitution you have do you have
recourse to Congress and that's exactly
what I did in 2002 and one you want I
mean I went to Congress to report some
of the the spying on the US citizens not
it's all alive when they tell you
they're after the Russians all they're
tapping points in the fairview program
are internal in the u.s. they're there
there's 11 points that they could pick
up every foreigner coming into or out of
or through the United States if they
stayed at those 11 points they get them
all you know what if they actually you
know the Russians that they didn't die
all they were doing was calling Hillary
names on Facebook not that bad guys
gotta run thank you